percentage of your staff did you fire at
Twitter I think we're about we're about
uh 20 of the original size so 80 left uh
yes I mean a lot of people voluntarily
sure sure but but it's 80 are gone from
the datejust correct yes so how do you
run the company with only 20 of the
staff uh it turns out uh you don't need
uh well that many people to run Twitter
but 80 that's a lot I mean if you're not
trying to run some sort of uh glorified
activist organization uh with both and
you don't care that much about
censorship then you can really let go of
a lot of people turns out
but about 80 percent of the people are
gone so he bought a faulty product with
a whole bunch of really bad useless
employees now the thing is slimmer and
trimmer and working and More in line
with the values that you and I share